during the 2016 election a Twitter
comedian posted a meme the meme was a
version of one of the oldest jokes in
Democratic politics I remember the joke
from when I was working on my first
campaign ever
a guy came up to one of my campaign
colleagues it was on on this
Congressional race and he asked when is
election day to which my friend not
missing a beat responded to pens are you
a democrat or a republican if you're a
republican go vote on Tuesday if you're
a Democrat wait until Wednesday or
Thursday
very basic joke so in 2016 this guy
Douglas Mackey whose entire account was
memes and jokes he posted a meme telling
Democrats not to bother actually voting
on Tuesday but instead to text their
vote to some obviously fake number
as a result of that joke New York
liberals have now convicted Mr Mackey of
conspiracy against rights and he now
faces 10 years in prison
for a joke
for the same joke actually that a
liberal named Christina Wong made the
exact same joke in the exact same
election the only difference is that
Christina Wong is a Democrat hey
everybody this is Christina Wong and uh
I'm coming out I'm a trump supporter and
I just want to remind all my fellow
Chinese Americans for Trump people of
color for Trump to vote vote for Trump
on Wednesday November 9th really
important day we're going to show this
country who's boss and that's our man
Donald Trump so don't forget to vote
Donald Trump on November 9th
get it it's the day after the election
and in case people missed the video joke
Wong typed it out another version of it
she said hey Trump supporters skip poll
lines at election 2016 and text in your
vote text votes are legit or vote
tomorrow on super Wednesday delivery was
a little bit on the nose but there it is
and of course Miss Wong has not been
arrested she faces no prison time her
tweet was not even taken down
please do not get the wrong idea I am
not mentioning this to complain
I'm not mentioning this in the vain hope
that by pointing out the hypocrisy I
will persuade the libs to change their
corrupt ways or that I will persuade
some supposedly neutral government to
apply the law evenly that way lies the
death of conservatism imagine if the
shoe were on the other phone can you
imagine if the rules were reversed no
that's not what I'm saying
I mentioned this only as another data
point for conservatives
some of whom still labor under the
delusion that our nation is a nation of
laws it is not we are living under an
increasingly totalitarian liberal regime
in which liberals can do pretty much
whatever they please and conservatives
can never do anything right
this is not the way that our Capital C
Constitution
instructs our country to run
but this is the way that our lower case
C Constitution really works under our
effective lowercase C Constitution
liberal crimes are jokes and
conservative jokes are crimes I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we've got a lot
coming up you want to see The Logical
conclusion of the transgender agenda
well in the Netherlands
the Dutch are now exposing little kids
to naked transgender identifying people
people who have butchered their bodies
you know stripping in front of children
they're putting the whole thing on TV
we'll get to that in just a moment first
though
on transgenderism and jokes did anybody
crack open a Bud Light over the weekend
I mercifully did not but Bud Light has
just become the latest company
to sponsor Dylan Mulvaney Dylan Mulvaney
the man and former Broadway star who
during the covid lockdowns decided to
dress up like a girl and go on Tick Tock
and achieve more Fame than he's ever had
before so now he is one of the most
famous women in America even though he
is a man
a lot of companies have endorsed him so
far we've got Ulta beauty house Labs
Crest toothpaste instacart EOS CeraVe
native Kate Spade all Hendricks and
KitchenAid a number of others and now
Bud Light as well
you know that regular Bud Light consumer
guy getting off a hard day of work over
in construction or something he comes
home and what does he want to do he
wants to crack open a can with a
transvestite on it is that right I'm not
so sure about that I really lucked out
on the whole Bud Light Dylan Mulvaney
controversy because I have never really
cared for Bud Light all that much at all
and in fact my preferred canned alcohol
white cloth is already so gay that it
does not need to prove its LGBT Bona
fides by sponsoring a transvestite so
I'm totally fine here I will continue to
enjoy my delicious canned black cherry
and mango hard Seltzer drinks but if if
I were a drinker of Bud Light I could
not continue to consume that
not knowing that they are endorsing this
guy by putting Dylan Mulvaney on the can
Bud Light is signaling to me and I
suspect
80 of the rest of America that they
don't want our business they just think
that we don't have any alternatives so
yes I am waiting for
Jeremy's lager Jeremy's ales I'm not
sure it's been more than 24 hours I
don't know what what Jeremy's slow down
is but we need we need the logger and
I'll be sipping the fruity Seltzer in
the meantime
in slightly less funny transgender
activism
there is a guy named billboard Chris
he's up in Canada he shows up to these
crazy trans rallies and he wears a sign
he's got a very simple message says
children cannot consent
that's it
he's not going so far as
I go in my speech when I say that
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely the whole
Preposterous ideology at every level
he's not going as far as everyone in
this country went before 2015 when we
did not tolerate transgenderism in
public life at all not in the bathrooms
not in the sports teams not nowhere
he's just saying children should not be
castrated sterilized butchered put on
cross-sex hormones should not be transd
and for that
he gets pummeled so it's power it is for
everybody all around you but probably
one so we honest you're bleeping it out
but here Fufu from all these
eccentric people holding all the trans
Flags the rainbow the baby blue and the
baby pink so a certain point they're
screaming so loudly in his face he just
starts videotaping them but then they
get really close I mean they're within
now a couple inches of his face and then
one of these dainty ladies with broad
shoulders and a huge Adam's apple one of
these dainty ladies just grabs him by
the throat and starts beating him up but
the craziest part of the video is
there are one two three four five six
seven eight nine at least nine or ten
cops there that's only what's in the
frame probably more and what do they do
pretty much nothing
they don't stop the transgender
identifying activists from shrieking in
this guy's face
spittle I'm certain landing on his face
they don't stop that and then the moment
that the the transvestite just starts
pummeling this dude they kind of they
start to walk toward it a little bit
they're kind of looking around they do
nothing
and of course if the roles were reversed
you know what would happen this would be
an international crisis
you know the cops would have been on
them like white on rice
but
the cops do nothing here
up in Canada it's like the Uvalde
mounties same thing happened to Alex
Stein in New York Alex Stein the
conservative comedian he goes to a
transgender rally and he says kids
basically the same thing kids can
consent you shouldn't trans the kids
you're sterilizing kids that's wrong to
do he's getting hot coffee thrown on him
he's getting beaten up he's being
grabbed and thrown around luckily he's a
pretty big guy and what does the NYPD do
nothing and I don't even think it's the
cops fault most New York cops I know are
pretty normal people they're pretty
pretty regular guys who don't think that
men or women and women are men I'm sure
they're just getting political orders
from the top saying if a normal person
attacks a transgender identifying
activist throw the book at him but if
the transgender identifying activists
attacks the normal person look the other
way
that's obviously what's going on we know
that's how our justice system works
because our justice system says
if a granny takes some selfies in the
capital rotunda on January 6th throw her
in solitary confinement but if BLM burns
the country down for eight months let
him off the hook
huge number of BLM Riot cases in
Manhattan in the Bronx all around New
York were just totally dismissed they
didn't even get a slap on the wrist
this is not a nation of laws this is mob
violence you saw the mob down in Texas
there was a a rally among the
transgender activists in Texas to to
stop Texas legislators from from
prohibiting the transgender Butchery on
little kids and
the the mob started shrieking just days
after that shooting where a transgender
identifying shooter targeted a Christian
school and killed little kids and their
teachers the the transgender activists
lie down in the hallway of this protest
to pretend to be dead they completely
flipped the script and here's how they
sound here's their really brilliant
articulate argument
look at the eyes
you can always toys the eyes you can
tell
there is something weird here going on
yeah and they're all focused on the
person filming shrieking screaming
middle fingers up
and when I was watching this clip all I
could hear was
you see these people just lying around
on the ground pretending to be dead
totally flipping the script of what
happened
all all I could hear when I saw this
clip
was
give us Barabbas that's all I could hear
I I know that's not what they were
literally saying but I thought this
is the way mobs always work some people
are incredulous that the mob would
behave this way
this is what mobs do
mobs murder people who speak the truth
and they crucify the truth himself
it has ever been thus
they make they make people drink Hemlock
they crucify the truth
this is it and so what are they talking
about here they're talking about trans
kids trans kids are the new democrat
Idol it's the new golden calf which
we'll get to in one second first though
speaking of gold you got to check out
Birch gold right now text Knowles to 98
98 98 you don't want to worship gold but
you might want to have some of your
assets in Gold to protect against
government uncertainty the FED has a
tendency to print money during times of
economic distress like they did during
the covid-19 lockdowns this has resulted
in the loss of the value of the dollar
and an increase in the value of precious
metals like gold gold will always have
value because it's tangible and a finite
resource uncontrolled by any single
government or financial institution gold
cannot simply be printed on a whim like
paper currency as the value of our
dollar continues to decline it becomes
increasingly important to hedge against
inflation by diversifying at least some
of your assets into precious metals
the only company that I trust to help
you diversify into precious metals is
Birch gold Birch gold also makes it easy
to convert your IRA or 401K into an IRA
backed by physical gold and silver
with an A plus rating from the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews Birch gold is the company I
trust to protect my future so should you
text Knowles kwels 98 9898 to claim your
free info kit on gold today and talk to
a precious metals expert that is Knowles
kwles to 98 98 98
trans kids that's the new democrat Idol
that's the new golden calf
this Democrat Idol is every bit as
Fantastical as the golden calf
and like the golden calf
this Democrat Idol involves child
sacrifice
what is the trans kid what is meant by
the trans kid what they mean is
children who are born into the wrong
body so it's children little boys but
they're really little girls really
somehow somewhere they're really little
girls but they're in the wrong body
and that's why we need to allow people
like Jeffrey Marsh and Dylan Mulvaney
and and the the drag queens of drag
queen Story Hour with criminal records
to go and and help these children to
come into their true selves by jiggling
around in front of them and presenting
them with gay porn like genderqueer by
Maya kababi and that will help them
become their true selves
but of course none of that is true
because it is not possible to be born
into the wrong body it is not possible
to be a man in body but a woman in
not body in spirit in Soul
metaphysically that's not possible
that's imaginary
that's the ideology of transgenderism
but the ideology of transgenderism is
wrong
and so the category of trans kid is an
illusion
certainly there can be children who are
confused about their sex and gender I
think that's true of many people when
they're going through puberty because
they're having so many changes to their
body which is which impels a lot of this
confusion that the Democrats are
exploiting to permanently sterilize
these kids but that can be people can
suffer confusion from their sex for all
sorts of different reasons if they've
been sexually abused that's a cause of a
lot of this sort of sexual confusion
a lot a lot of other issues contribute
to this that's all real the confusion
can be real but
the the category of transgender kid is
not real
that is an idol established by the
Democrats
Liberals by the radicals by the leftists
called whatever you want to call them
and that's the new one that's the one
they're going to focus on that's their
new object of worship
and they're objects of worship going
back to the pagans of old somehow always
come down to child sacrifice and in this
case the worship is the child sacrifice
it's abusing the children it's
butchering the children it's castrating
the children it's all of the above it is
it is a encouraging them to adopt an
ideology that has a huge correlation
with suicidality talk about child
sacrifice
it's
sick Pagan demonic evil
and it was unfortunately ever thus we
we've done a good job at various times
in our history at suppressing this kind
of movements but as religiosity has
declined as the prayer has gone out of
schools as Church tends has declined
these Pagan practices crop up again
speaking of religious expression
people might not believe in heaven so
much anymore people might not go to
church so much anymore in fact religious
belief is declining but this is what's a
little weird belief in hell is
increasing
according to a recent Pew research
report
62 percent of American adults believe in
hell
that's up from 58 percent in 2014.
and we're seeing this in the pop culture
we're seeing Sam Smith dance around like
the devil we're seeing all sorts of
occult imagery
I'm not terribly surprised by this
people might think it's a little weird
to believe in hell if you don't believe
in heaven and you don't believe in
Redemption you don't believe in God but
I don't think it's all that weird people
see evidence of hell all around them you
see evidence of hell when you turn on
the news
good stuff doesn't make the news bad
stuff makes the news it's very difficult
to deny evil
if you think that it's better to bake a
pie for a widow than to kick an orphan
in the head then you understand that
some things are better than other things
some things are worse than other things
and we see a lot of evil around us
and I think providentially this can be a
tool for
ultimately for good
this can be a tool for a greater
spiritual understanding is if you can
acknowledge some things are bad and you
know what to stand against
you have to ask well what's better
if some things are better then that
means that there's got to be a highest
good what is that highest good what does
this mean for my religious life
maybe the only way out is through it's
kind of like Dante's Divine Comedy the
only way he can get to heaven is going
all the way down and seeing all the way
to the pit of Hell and crawling through
hell coming out up to purgatory and up
to the tippy tippy top now in the midst
of our extreme
polarization and disagreement we have
a new residential candidate possibly
and it's not just a republican it's a
Democrat
but he sometimes seems like a republican
that man
West Virginia senator Joe manchin
are you open to running for president on
that ticket Dana first of all I'm worn
out that people were tired sick and
tired of the fighting and division that
we have and dividing the country Abraham
Lincoln said a divided divided we cannot
stand we cannot basically have a divided
country and we cannot withstand that we
have to come together so are you
considering running for president we
have a movement there's a there's a
movement there's a movement going on
that people want to bring the extremes
back to the sensible and reasonable
responsible middle do you want to lead
that movement trying to get a dialogue I
I'm trying to get a dialogue to where
people were saying come on this is
ridiculous Don't force people to go to
the extremes
so Joe manchin obviously wants to run
for president he's been teasing this for
months now
I personally do not support a Centrist
run because the political Center has
moved so far to the left
so far to the left just to give one
example that keeps cropping up in 2012
in 2008 rather Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton both ran for president saying
that marriage is the sacred Union
between a man and a woman
now in 2023 many Republicans refused to
even say that men and women exist as
real natural distinct categories the
center is totally moved to the left so
if we Embrace a Centrist campaign then
we're embracing radical leftism of just
a few years ago but there would be an
argument for a Centrist campaign because
the libs wield all the power in the
country the libs can throw our guys in
prison for telling jokes but they'll let
their guys off the hook for burning the
country down
we know that there's a two-tiered system
of justice we know that the libs run
pretty much everything the media the
schools technology all the big Tech
platforms that control our speech the
corporations including Bud Light they
they run the bureaucracy they run much
of the elected governments they run
everything they've got all the power so
if you could reign in That Power by
putting a slightly more moderate
Democrat into office there would at
least be an argument for it
I wouldn't support it but there would be
an argument for it problem is the
Democrats have no appetite for
moderation
why would they they've got all the power
they're they're doing whatever they want
they're pushing their liberal political
project all the way to the liberation of
the self from the body I mean they're
just they're going totally
for their ultimate goals
why would they moderate so he would
never get out of a primary
even if Joe Biden collapses on the
campaign Trail there will be a Gavin
Newsom or someone else to pick up the
pieces someone to the left
seems fairly doomed for Mr Mansion but
he keeps on floating it
he's going to want to protect his
political interests you're going to want
to protect your family that's why you
got to check out my Patriot Supply head
on over to preparewithknolls.com it's
hard to trust anything or anyone these
days if you've been paying attention to
current events at all the past few years
you know that you need to be prepared
for anything there is no better place to
start than by having a supply of
emergency food on hand right now my
Patriot Supply is knocking 200 off their
popular three-month emergency food kit
go to preparewithknolls.com grab this
special price before it ends your
three-month emergency food kit provides
over 2 000 calories each day for optimal
strength and energy in stressful
situations enjoy a wide variety of
breakfasts lunches dinners drinks and
snacks best of all it's delish don't put
off your preparedness any longer
tomorrow may be too late go to prepare
with knowles.com save 200 on each kit
your family needs our website is prepare
with knowles.com right now go to prepare
with knowles.com you will have peace of
mind
your family will be protected you can
sleep sound at night and with the way
things are going in our politics
you might just need it my favorite
comment on Friday is from Werner Mina
who says when they bleep Michael I like
to imagine him saying actual profanities
and that takes me back to my my days in
New York speaking like
someone of my true Italian upbringing
that's that's great even though usually
the words that they're bleeping are
words such as delusion or I don't know
more ideological kinds of words but
that's kind of funny imagining that
they're four letter words I get into
that I'll get into that
okay
uh
this is the most disturbing video
[Music]
not that I've ever seen but it's up
there
a Dutch TV show is promoting
transgenderism and specifically
transgenderism to kids by taking a group
of little kids specifically minors and
then bringing in a bunch of transgender
identifying confused people and having
them strip naked and having the kids
look at their bodies
Simply Naked adults get undressed these
kids 10 to 12 years old get the
opportunity to ask them questions about
their naked body and today our guests
are transgenders I couldn't believe this
was real at first
yes that feeling can simply be a feeling
but you can also do something about it
for example I had surgery
you can also be transgender and not
undergo any surgeries
as you can see there's something in my
Underpants but I still have a vulva I
don't feel comfortable with that body
part therefore I'm wearing my underwear
with a packer I think that means like a
cucumber or something vaginoplasty what
does that mean
that you surgically change the male sex
organs the female sex organ says this
dude with implants
and here's a girl who's 10 years old
later you realize it's actually pretty
normal it's actually really normal says
this 10 year old boy well it's not just
male and female there's an entire
spectrum of gender is besides male and
female says this pervert host how did
you feel after you had surgery
euphoric means extremely happy but put a
pause there
this to me is the most disturbing part
of the video the whole thing's
disturbing these kids are so little
these people are so naked they're
talking about sex
reminds me of that Meme from Oren
McIntyre which I was somewhat skeptical
of but
every day it seems truer and truer which
is it's a meme of a guy pointing to a
sign and says it's not that complicated
they just want to diddle kids
these are adult people stripping naked
talking about sex and sexual Euphoria to
10 year old kids boys and girls on TV
they're not hiding this this is not in
some CD alley they're putting it all out
there
they're not hiding the gay porn for the
little kids they're putting it right
there in the elementary school library
they're campaigning on it
and then this woman says
do you know the word Euphoria little
kids saying no I don't know what
Euphoria is says I woke up and I knew my
breasts were gone that I looked like I
had always wanted it to look and I was
euphoric I was ecstatic I felt the best
and happiest I could ever feel do you
want to feel that way kids that's
obviously the implication
kids are always chasing some kind of
high some kind of short-term feeling of
of excitement that's why they run and
eat the candy bars and eat too many
cookies in the cookie jar and go crazy
they're kids they don't have control
over their over their rational will
and this
woman I get is a woman I think or a man
I don't know says oh I yeah I guess it's
a woman because she had her breasts
removed
she says oh yeah it's so euphoric
just planting that seed let me know if
you want to chop them off keep going
okay
finally match the way that I feel inside
and that made me feel ecstatic
because it feels a bit like flying yes
you simply feel intense
happiness to little kids obviously we've
blurred and censored this whole clip
in the original Ain't blurred okay and
so people are gonna watch this they say
wow that's really crazy the reason I
bring it up at all is because
this is exactly what the libs are doing
here in the United States there's no
difference
the Dutch are a little more Brazen about
these things they sometimes seem a
little more avant-garde
and when they go live they go all the
way lib when they introduce assisted
suicide for instance
it's not just a handful of people who
are in extreme pain at the very end of
their lives very quickly they start just
murdering people they hold grannies down
and kill them against their will they
start killing young people they start
pushing it on children
but we're doing the same thing here
there is a very good chance that if your
kids are in elementary school right now
they will have access to a book in their
Library called genderqueer by Maya
kababi which is just a book version of
this show it's just a book with very
graphic weird sex in it that's available
in many many elementary schools around
the country
when the
Biden Administration starts pushing
quote unquote gender affirming care onto
kids of all all ages and they reiterated
their support for that last week they're
doing the same thing that these guys are
doing when they push sex education at
younger and younger ages when they push
back against Ron desantis's Bill in
Florida that says you can't do this kind
of stuff until the kids enter fourth
grade
you can only kindergarten to third grade
you're not allowed to push this stuff
and then the libs go epiplectic over it
protect trans kids protect trans kids by
allowing us to strip down naked in front
of them and telling them to euphoric to
chop their genitals off
we in America are doing the same well
not you and I are not doing it but the
Liberals are doing the very same thing
here in America it's like it's like the
new flag of our country in fact Richard
Levine
good old dick Levine who now goes by
Rachel
he is the assistant Secretary of Health
at the Department of Health and Human
Services he thinks that he is
a woman
he just bragged about the new flag
flying over HHS happy transgender day of
his ability I am Admiral Rachel Levine
the assistant secretary for health at
the Department of Health and Human
Services for the second year in a row
the transgender flag is flying above our
department in Washington D.C and this is
an affirmation of the administration's
support for the transgender community
and Across the Nation as well as our
support for evidence-based gender
affirming care
produced by the U.S Department of Health
and Human Services
produced by HHS this is the flag of the
liberal Empire I've pointed this out for
a long time there are two flags that
purport to represent America there's the
old Stars and Stripes the Star-Spangled
Banner that's the flag of the
traditional American Nation
then there's the rainbow flag and the
pride progress flag and the trans flag
they're all just variations on a theme
in the way that we have the Betsy Ross
flag and the Gadsden flag and the Grand
Union Flag those were all early American
national flags
so too we have these early American
Imperial Flags
those rainbow flags are the flags of our
Empire of the liberal Empire
and they're specifically geared to be
liberal Imperial Flags because they
don't respect any borders they're not
just about America they're coming from
America but they're supposed to apply
everywhere in the world this is why when
the Liberals run the government when the
Biden Administration runs the government
they go into the Vatican and they hoist
a rainbow flag this is obviously
contrary to Christian teaching it's
contrary to Jewish teaching and Muslim
teaching and
most normal teaching throughout all of
human history in all sorts of cultural
and religious systems but they go and
they specifically hoist that flag
because that that is a statement that
our beliefs on weird sexual practices
and chopping off genitals and pretending
to be the opposite sex and our our
cultish views on this they apply to
everybody it's not just for us it's for
everybody we've got to stay in
Afghanistan to project LGBT LMNOP rights
we have to
people and people have a fundamental
right to chop off their genitals and we
need to commit another 20 years and who
knows
how much in the way of treasure and the
efforts and potentially lives of our
service members to defend LGBT LMNOP
rights in Kandahar right
that's what they do I promise you if you
pulled 100 Libs
and you said which flag do you identify
more with the rainbow flag or the Stars
and Stripes
a significant portion probably the
majority would say the rainbow flag
that's the flag of the liberal Empire
it's not just at HHS with a confused
under secretary it's true of the White
House Joe Biden
days after a transgender identifying
shooter targeted and massacred little
Christian kids at a Christian School
Joe Biden posts this to his social media
accounts
on transgender day of visibility we want
you to know that we see you just as you
are made in the image of God and
deserving of dignity respect and support
will never stop working to create a
world where you won't have to be brave
just to be yourself
Be Yourself by by denying who you are of
course
could you imagine
if you were
a family member of a victim of that
shooting
in Nashville
and the White House response to that
shooting was we love transgenderism yeah
we totally we totally support the
transgender ideology the ideology that
according to the chief of police was
very likely
a motivating factor if not the sole
motivating factor for this shooting yet
we love that ideology that's our
favorite ideology
but the White House has to do this
the White House has to do this because
the transgenderists have to be the
victims
they have to be the victims
because this this is the ultimate
almost this is the penultimate
stop
in the liberal political project
the Liberals have already liberated us
from tradition liberated us from normal
religion liberated us from National
boundaries liberated us from customs and
mores now they're liberating us from our
biology the the Last Frontier will be to
liberate us from Humanity itself that's
called transhumanism transgenderism is
just a step on the way to transhumanism
they're talking about this this isn't
tin foil hat stuff you're hearing this
from Yuval Harare you're hearing this
from the world economic Forum you're
hearing this from all sorts of people
who say within a matter of just a few
years we're going to start merging with
technology we're going to improve our
brains we're going to improve our bodies
ultimately we're going to upload our
Consciousness into the cloud somewhere
we won't need our bodies anymore we're
already doing that through technology in
the sense that we live most of our Lives
virtually on our phones in the Oculus in
the metaverse in on social media
this is
necessary
to the liberal political project
who are who are the victims here
who are the victims here
well you're seeing this play out
you're seeing it totally
um
you're seeing it play out even after a
shooting the Liberals have to double
down there's no way out of it now what
do you do if you're the the target of
this mob what do you do if your
billboard Chris what do you do if you
are being shouted down while filming in
Texas what if you what do you do if
you're Alex Stein being beaten up by the
mob and you see the cops just standing
around doing nothing
it's probably a good sign that you're on
the right side
all of this is foretold in the Bible all
of this is foretold in non-biblical
sources as well
if you're being attacked by the mob
you're probably saying something right
if you're getting a lot of Praise from
the world then you're probably doing
something wrong if you're getting a lot
of Praise from the world
very likely
very likely uh you're on the wrong side
because this world is governed by the
devil is governed by principalities and
powers and spiritual awakenness in high
places and people know it and that's why
more and more people believe in hell
even if they don't believe in heaven and
they don't believe in God now some some
really great news when we're pushing
back against this liberal Empire
occasionally we get a little bit of
power back we see this on on Twitter
this would be Elon Musk
Elon Musk just removed the verification
Badge of the New York Times
uh Elon Musk tweeted out the real
tragedy of the New York Times is that
their propaganda is not even interesting
also their feed is the Twitter
equivalent of diarrhea it's unreadable
they would have far more real followers
if they only posted their top articles
same applies to all Publications
love it absolutely love it Elon said he
was going to start taking away people's
verification badges on April 1st if they
didn't pay Seven dollars a month I'm not
paying seven dollars a month last I
checked I still have my verification
badge I love that Elon went for the New
York Times first they don't deserve any
credibility and any chance we get to get
a billionaire who's sympathetic to our
side who can wield some power because
money talks and Bs walks I just think
that's absolutely great none of these
people deserve any of your respect the
fact that our criminal justice system
now very clearly has two different
tracts the fact that Christians are
constantly castigated and denigrated
even when they're attacked even when
they're murdered and transgender
confused people
are are always the victim no matter what
at the Tennessee State Capitol
protesters showed up they showed up on
the on the day of Vengeance day of
visibility they held up seven fingers
the protest said there were seven
victims there were the six people who
were murdered but that seventh person
the shooter she's the real victim here
they that that is just the beginning if
a granny shows up to the Capitol in
support of Donald Trump she has to be a
terrorist if a terrorist shows up and
attacks conservatives kills people BLM
kills dozens of people burns down
buildings attacks courthouses it doesn't
matter they have to be the victim
Society made them do it that's
that's the premise okay and you're not
gonna convince them otherwise by
pointing out the hypocrisy but at the
very least you can finish your fellow
conservatives what the stakes are and
people tell us they want a Centrist run
for president give me a break
this is our life folks sometimes you're
going to want to remember the Great
Moments in your life you want to paint
your life right now text Knowles to
87204 are you looking for a unique gift
idea paint your life creates
hand-painted portraits that fit almost
any budget and it's a great gift idea
for those you love upload photos to
create anything you imagine put yourself
in a location you've always wanted to go
or add a lost loved one to a special
occasion to create the portrait of your
dreams you can choose the artist art
medium oil acrylic watercolor charcoal
they've got a great selection of quality
frames their user-friendly platform lets
you order a custom made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes I
have one hanging in my living room I've
got a portrait of my my mother and it's
it's just so beautiful I was a little
skeptical at first I said there's no way
you can get a really high quality oil
oil portrait this way it's just
beautiful I get so many compliments on
it I've given Paint Your Life paintings
out to to people for weddings it's just
it's a phenomenal service go to paint
your life right now they're offering our
listeners 20 off plus free shipping text
nulls to 87204 that is Knowles kwles to
87204 paint your life and celebrate the
moments that matter most message and
data rates may apply C terms for details
I know what you're thinking you're
thinking Michael
how do you get your hair so shiny and
voluminous and spectacular the answer is
Jeremy's razors shampoo and conditioner
that's right folks Jeremy's razors is
more than just a razor company fighting
to protect your beliefs it is also a
Men's Grooming brand
that does not hate men This Magnificent
cloth you see here is fortified every
morning thanks to Jeremy's tea tree and
Argan Oil infused shampoo and
conditioner but that's not all oh no
Jeremy's also has an exfoliating
charcoal body wash made with hydrating
aloe vera eucalyptus and just the right
amount of pomegranate
the men's care products that you see
here are made with natural ingredients
they're 100 sulfate free paraben free
woke free and made right here in the U.S
of a head on over to jeremy'srazors.com
to kick woke companies out of your
bathroom
today what do we do about it with all
this confusion JD Vance has an answer
JD Vance's answer is to make English the
official language of the United States
this bill is called the English language
Unity Act
this would essentially establish English
as the official language and task
representatives of the federal
government with the obligation of what
the legislation describes as preserving
and enhancing the role of English as the
official language of the federal
government so this obligation shall
include
greater opportunities for individuals to
learn the English language
and it will require official functions
of the government to be conducted in
English the rule would apply to all laws
public proceedings regulations
Publications orders actions programs and
policies I think this is absolutely
great
the libs are going to call this
authoritarian
just like they call me authoritarian
like they call you authoritarian like
they call anything they don't like
authoritarian
I don't think the word authoritarian
really means anything anymore I think
authoritarian means wielding political
power and the conservatives are so
afraid of being called authoritarian
that they they won't ever wield
political power it's just one of those
words that is used to stop us from doing
anything it's like the word racist
racist doesn't mean anything anymore if
it ever did it certainly doesn't mean
anything now and it's just a word used
to say hey conservatives anything you
want to do if you do it we'll call you
racist so just don't do it
I'm not authoritarian by Nature I'm sure
you're not either
but
when you have a healthy unified culture
you have less of a need to codify things
into law when you have a culture that's
fragmented that can't agree on basic
things they can't even speak to one
another then you have more of an
obligation to codify things into law
including what language you speak
officially
societies that are healthy don't need to
write everything down they just know it
they've got it in their bones they've
got it in Tradition there are people
that has been unified for a very long
time they share the same views they were
raised in the same way we don't have
that in America we don't have that in
America because of the poison of
liberalism working its way through our
culture we don't have that in America
because we've imported millions and
millions of people over the last 60
years
the largest movement of people in the
history of the world who might be very
wonderful people but they're just they
weren't raised and acculturated into our
civilization and so they just we're just
more fragmented and so in that case you
need the heavy hand of the law
to be a little bit clearer to spell out
for people who weren't raised this way
what to do
this is a great a great move
I remember
about 10 years ago I was coming up in
Republican politics I thought
let's put those cultural issues aside
let's just talk about economic issues
those are winning issues we'll deal with
that first then we can deal with all of
the cultural problems
a lot of people are probably thinking we
should do that right now because
a huge number of Americans are getting
squeezed 44 of Americans are working a
second job right now
that's a 13 increase relative to the
Trump Administration this according to a
Lending Club report
a recent increase under Joe Biden
found that 69 percent of employed
professionals either have a side job or
want a side job
don't you think we should put the
cultural issues second and just deal
with this economic issue first that's
what I used to think that's what a lot
of us used to think that was the moment
of Paul Ryan that was the moment of Eric
Cantor that was the moment of the
reformacon so let's focus on the the
fiscal stuff then the let's have a
social truce we'll do that and then
we'll deal with the social stuff later
but no the lesson of the ensuing 10
years is that
economic issues are cultural issues they
are social issues if you don't fix the
social and cultural issues you're never
going to fix the economic issues
if you don't fix the issue of what is
The American Nation who gets to come in
and be an American can we rely on our
elections and our political institutions
do we respect Humanity
do we respect innocent life we're not
going to Snuff it out in the womb if if
you if you don't respect the life of an
innocent little baby you're not going to
respect anybody in business you're not
going to respect any of your
constituents you're not going to respect
the promises that you've made to your
constituents down the road when it comes
to say entitlements if you don't respect
if you don't understand what the
American nation is you're not going to
have any sense of how we should conduct
our trade policy how we should conduct
our manufacturing policy
you can't do it
the cultural stuff has to come first if
we do not speak the same language
we don't have a country
there are other nations
that don't totally speak the same
language I think of Switzerland speaks a
bunch of different now in fact the Swiss
just speak a lot of different languages
so all of them speak a lot a lot of
different languages but the Swiss are
united by a lot by a shared Culture by a
small clearly defined geography they're
the same people they're this they've
been the same people for a very long
time
they have roughly the same religion
none of that is true in America anymore
so it doesn't work and into this into
this melee comes another on top of
potentially Joe manchin we have now
another
potential residential candidate
that would be former Arkansas governor
ASA Hutchinson when I spoke to you
earlier this year you said you were
thinking about running for president
have you made a decision are you running
I have made a decision and my decision
is I'm going to run for president of the
United States while the formal
announcement will be later in April
Bentonville I wanted to make clear that
to you Jonathan I am going to be running
ASA Hutchinson has become most famous in
recent years for
defending transiting the kids he's a
republican governor who was very upset
when the Republican legislators wanted
to to pass a bill
preventing quacks from transiting
children
so hard to imagine that Governor
Hutchinson's campaign will go very far
we keep an open mind one statistic's
important here though
after Trump's indictment was announced
he raised four million dollars in 24
hours
we'll get more into that tomorrow shows
you though where the appetite of the
party is where the appetite of the
conservative bases where the appetite of
the country is because a million dollars
of that was from first-time donors
people see how far the culture has
lurched to the left
a Centrist campaign puts that way more
to the left
and that's not what people want people
want the pendulum actually to swing back
and to swing this pendulum back from
getting naked having having butchered
people get naked in front of kids and
talking about sexual euphoria
having the pendulum swing back from we
don't have a Common Language anymore
is going to require a candidate
who seems by today's standards to be
very very right wing those are the
candidates who are going to raise the
money it's music Monday Baby the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member use code
knowleskin wlas at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]